[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: When you think
of motorcycle gangs,
this is what most
people imagine,
a group straight out
of "Sons of Anarchy."
Thugs and criminals who probably
terrorize the road every time
they ride out.
But not all motorcycle
gangs have the same agenda.
MICHAEL SHARKEY: Hi, my
name is Michael Sharkey.
And I'm a portrait photographer
living in Brooklyn, New York.
This is just one
of many photographs
I made that day, documenting
the Empire City Motorcycle Club,
or ECMC, New York City's
oldest gay biker gang.
The club was formed
in 1964 at a time when
there were very few places
in the city gay men could
gather and be themselves.
SPEAKER: When the club was
founded more than 50 years ago,
the LGBT rights movement
was in its infancy.
Older members recall how
coming out was a big risk.
MICHAEL SHARKEY: While
researching the project,
I had the pleasure of speaking
with one of ECMC's oldest
members, Emil Solis.
He joined the Empire
City Motorcycle Club
with his partner
Bill in June of 1965.
And he told me at that
time it was very dangerous.
You could be fired or evicted
if your boss or landlord didn't
like the way you looked.
SPEAKER: And there was also the
very real threat of violence.
So the Empire City
Motorcycle Club
really provided a
sanctuary from all that.
And today members often
comment that it gives them
a sense of unity too.
MICHAEL SHARKEY: The reason I
titled the series, Brotherhood
of Men, is because in the
course of speaking to each
of the members, it became clear
that the most important thing
to each of them was a sense
of family and camaraderie,
friendship, and brotherhood.
SPEAKER: The Empire City
Motorcycle Club was and still
is an integral part of the gay
community in New York because
of the sense of brotherhood.
The club events and group
rides bring together
like minded folks from
the gay community,
which is what compelled Michael
to take pictures of them.
MICHAEL SHARKEY: As a
gay man, I'm certainly
drawn to gay subjects.
But I think more generally, I'm
drawn to marginalized groups
and to subjects that
exist outside the norm.
These guys are obviously
doing something
that they truly love and
with people that they really
care about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: For a whole
lot more Seeker
Stories, be sure
to click Subscribe.
It's really the best way
to make sure you never
miss any of our episodes.
And thanks for watching.